so after notching some wins last week
the failed former president donald trump
has a pretty serious endorsement failure
on his hands now as the alleged serial
groper
charles herbster has suffered a primary
defeat although trump did get a win in
west virginia last night so we're going
to talk about it as well as the
implications the big news of course
trump backed herbster accused of groping
loses to pillon in nebraska that was the
nebraska gubernatorial mooney wins in
west virginia the mixed results for
trump came in contests pitting him
against local republican leaders as a
reminder here is donald trump talking
about uh the great charles herbster a
crew accused of groping at least eight
women
[Music]
[Applause]
the audio at that event clearly run by
antifa as you can tell but we could tell
what trump was saying which is he is
endorsing herbster and herbster is good
and herbster is going to win
but sadly for him
herbster lost the results are that jim
pillin has won the republican primary
in nebraska for the gubernatorial race
jim pillin it was close it was close
basically 34 to 30
um with a third candidate brett
lindstrom coming in at roughly 26
with just the omaha area um so that is a
defeat for donald trump uh what are the
takeaways well interesting article from
the new york times one takeaway is trump
still did get a win in west virginia on
paper west virginia's new second
congressional district should have given
an advantage to mckinley who previously
represented a larger area seeking a
seventh term
but mooney 50 years old who once led the
republican party in neighboring maryland
romped across nearly the entire district
trump's endorsement is widely seen as
powering the mooney campaign in one of
the states where the former president
has been more pop most popular
trump also referring to mckinley as a
i'm sorry mooney referring to mckinley
as a rhino which has been a popular
attack
for uh donald trump so so far this
primary season
you know the the j.r majewski thing is
complicated because j.r majewski pledged
loyalty to trump he was on his knees for
trump praying at the altar of trump but
trump didn't actually endorse majewski
but after majewski won trump said like
hey i didn't even really know about this
guy but he's a trump guy and he's great
uh so now sort of like an endorsement
going into the general but listen
trump's record so far is pretty good 75
roughly depending on how you calculate
it and the reason we care about this is
not so much because trump claims he has
a perfect endorsement record when it's
really a pretty average endorsement
record over the last five years that's
not actually why we care about this we
care about this because we know
that among whether trump is in a lot of
legal trouble and whether trump has
health problems that another factor that
will influence whether trump tries to
run again in 2024 is whether he
perceives that he can easily win at
minimum the republican nomination if not
the general
and one of the ways that he and we and
others will be able to ascertain whether
he's got a shot at the republican
nomination at minimum is whether his
endorsement continues to carry
significant weight in the 2022 midterms
and so far it's certainly carrying some
weight in fact i would even venture to
say it's very early but so far
trump's record in 2022
is better than his overall record over
the last few years it's very early we
have only a handful of races and over
the next month and really over the next
yeah roughly the next four or five weeks
we're going to have a number of
additional primaries trump putting out a
series of endorsements yesterday on his
website and many of them are incumbents
so you know when
is it really a big win
if you endorse an incumbent and the
incumbent wins i would argue no but all
of it is what can you justify
what can you convince your followers of
and so far trump is doing okay although
i mean listen
going with the eight times accused
serial groper
in uh nebraska
maybe it was destined not to go
particularly well now later we're going
to talk about elon musk saying that if
he finishes his purchase of twitter
he would unban donald trump from the
platform i'll give my thoughts on that
later
merely anecdotally
i kind of would love to see what trump
would be tweeting about his herbster
endorsement right now if he were on
twitter
he would probably be saying something
like were it not for the fake phony
fraudulent allegations of groping
i would have gotten the endorsement win
but the left made it up and
you know something like that that's my
guess of what trump would be saying
about this race if he were on twitter
but
it's good that herbster lost herbster's
a disaster
and the fact that it's a loss for trump
just makes it a little bit better
i got an email yesterday from slug
about the topic
of the left needing better arguments
when it comes to the topic of abortion
in other words the the left needs to be
better prepared
and better articulate the absurdity of
the right-wing position on abortion
rights and the obvious logic
of the left-wing position on abortion
rights in the united states and slug
pointed out in this email to me which
which was really great a thoughtful
email that one of the main topics of
discussion in the abortion rights debate
in the united states at least
between just people who engage in in the
topic
when does life begin is this major topic
of discussion is it a person or not
exactly when does life begin
what about personhood and then we say
i would i would argue accurately so well
if it's a person five weeks after
conception
then should there be child support for
that person at five weeks after
conception should there be citizenship
even if it if the fetus
is the child of an undocumented
immigrant if it's a person at five weeks
then maybe there should be citizenship
and if so that means you can't deport a
pregnant woman regardless of her
immigration status because she has a
real person in the woo so you know
there's all these conversations and it's
fine
but slug argues
that it's a waste of time in the sense
that at the end of the day
it really is a philosophical question
and in a sense a religious question or a
philosophical question informed by
religion the anti-choice right isn't
going to accept arguments from doctors
anyway imagine that imagine that doctors
could say hey you know what uh it's a
person after 27 weeks
the right's not going to accept that
anyway so maybe it's sort of a futile
effort to debate that and at the end of
the day
we don't make law on philosophical or
religious beliefs or at least we
shouldn't
although we know that fundamentally
christianity is at the core of much of
anti-abortion sentiment in the united
states fine
so slug's idea is the right says
abortion is murder
so the state can legislate around
abortion on the basis that it's like
murder
but really
we should be saying no no no abortion is
more like organ or tissue donation this
is the idea
and in fact
before the fetus is viable outside the
womb
it's really a lot like organ and tissue
donation in terms of our legal framework
around it we don't force people ever to
give away an organ or to donate blood or
to donate plasma or plasma as trump used
to call it or bone marrow we don't do
that even in some cases and there are
many of them where someone needs blood
or bone marrow or an organ to survive
right there there's a life on the line
we never legislate that you have to do
this thing you have to donate bone
marrow or whatever the case may be and
in fact people regularly require those
uh uh
donations to survive and many people
don't get them and they die people die
on waiting lists all the time
that's tragic
but we don't force anyone to go under
the knife and donate a kidney or get
hooked up to uh um uh you know it's not
an iv it's a
to get hooked up to have a blood or
plasma or whatever taken and we never
charge people who don't do those things
with murder nor manslaughter it's never
even part of the conversation you've got
to register as an organ donor to even be
contacted corpses can't even be
harvested for anything without written
permission right
if forcing organ or tissue or blood
donation is considered too invasive for
anyone to ever talk about doing it by
law
how is forcing a woman to lend her
uterus for a fetus to develop
acceptable since it's even more of an
invasion of privacy and a violation of
bodily autonomy than donating blood or
plasma or a kidney the fetus uses the
mother's body for nine months it causes
permanent changes it risks health issues
it potentially you can even die through
pregnancy not to mention obviously the
responsibility being placed on the
mother for 18 plus years 25 plus years
35 plus years some of some other
millennials will understand so the idea
here is from slug
maybe the left should stop arguing
about when life begins
and start forcing the anti-choicers to
admit
they think the fetus deserves more
rights than everyone else and women
deserve less bodily autonomy than
everyone else it's still sort of an
in-process idea that a viewer sent to me
i wanted to share it with you
send me your thoughts as to whether you
think this might be a better angle or a
useful angle and again remember
it's not so much about convincing
the anti-choice right wingers it's about
framing the argument
in terms that aren't subject to just
philosophy i mean we don't force organ
donation we just don't and lives do
depend on it
we don't force tissue donation blood
donation whatever and lives do depend on
it if we don't do that
the invasion of forcing a woman to carry
a pregnancy to term is far more
significant and so how do we justify
that doesn't seem to make any sense let
me know what you think we'll do a
follow-up you can find me on twitter at
deepakman and i want to mention again
and we are seeing
what's happening with our mailing list
is out of this world on monday i
mentioned that on memorial day we're
going to do a one-day membership special
we're going to blow out memberships to
finish out may we may run out of
memberships quite frankly
at a major discount we're doing it on a
holiday because my lawyer would never
allow me to do this on a business day he
would say no no no no don't this is too
cheap our accountant would say david
this is terrible business manager would
say it's too big of a discount so i'm
doing this on a federal holiday while
they're all sleeping and not paying
attention
monday memorial day get on our mailing
list at davidpakman.com
you'll get an email
telling you
here's the discount code
it's good today only
become a member and you'll get all the
perks that come with membership the
bonus show of course which alex jones
hates oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad he's
furious about it uh the commercial free
audio feed of the show the commercial
free video feed of the show priority
access during viewer town halls the next
of which i'll be announcing soon so all
you have to do today
is get on the mailing list at
davidpakman.com
and then you'll hear from us on memorial
day
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
in the midst of everything happening
with the supreme court we learned last
week through this leaked decision that
in all likelihood unless something
changes the current supreme court is
going to be voting to overturn roe v
wade as soon as the end of june in the
midst of all of this protests at the
houses of supreme court justices etc etc
and of course the search for the leaker
which i really wonder how that's going
um public confidence in the supreme
court has absolutely collapsed from
where it was
there is a new poll
confidence in supreme court collapsed
since conservatives took control
this is a new yahoo news yougov poll
which shows that over the last 20 months
american confidence in the court
has collapsed this is a period that
started with trump and republicans
putting in that 6-3 conservative
majority with the replacement of ruth
bader ginsburg by amy coney barrett
and that uh this has culminated with the
leak of the draft signaling that roe v
wade will be overturned
the last time yahoo yougov asked about
confidence in the court was september of
2020 that was just a few days after ruth
bader ginsburg died then
70 percent of registered voters said
they had some or a lot of confidence in
the court
whereas 30 said they had a little or
none
in the new survey
a 40-point swing where now only half of
voters expect some or a lot of
confidence
while the other half now expresses a
little or no support
that is uh those are incredible numbers
and as the article points out
views on key aspects of american life
rarely shift that suddenly and the
question is why
the question is why now there's tons of
speculation as to why but one important
element of this to understand
is that we now have
five of the nine justices on the court
appointed by presidents who lost the
popular vote so just take a step back
for a second
most americans believe that abortion
should be legal in most cases americans
are more in favor of abortion today than
at any point during the roe v wade era
and we have this forthcoming decision
where the supreme court is going to say
no we're getting rid of roe v wade
abortion isn't even going to be a right
anymore okay well let's look at the
makeup it's a 6-3 conservative court in
which five of the nine justices were
chosen by presidents who lost the
popular vote uh george w bush selected
uh chief justice roberts and samuel
alito
donald trump selected uh neil gorsuch
brett kavanaugh and amy coney barrett
five of the nine the loser of the
popular vote got to pick okay that's
number one number two
those choices again made by a president
who lost the popular vote were confirmed
by a completely anti-democratic senate
in which california with 30 something
million people
and wyoming with under a million people
i hope i'm getting these population
numbers correct 30 something million one
under one million
california and wyoming have the same
number of votes
consider the lopsided and undemocratic
nature of this and of course we have to
also say
one of those seats should have been
barack obama's choice should have been
merrick garland but thanks to mitch
mcconnell
from the completely anti-democratic
senate being able to obstruct that
nomination long enough for donald trump
to eventually install neil gorsuch so
it makes sense
that
with such a prominent decision now in
the forefront you would have
americans saying i i don't i'm not
confident in this court i don't approve
of what this court is doing and
some you know coleman hughes yesterday
said
it's a feature of the supreme court that
it is sort of insulated from public
pressure public opinion etc
that's fine that would be a feature to
me as well as as i thought about it
overnight i came to this realization
that's all well and good assuming we're
confident about the way we got to these
nine people on the court and and i'm not
i'm not i mean again
losing two presidents who lost the
popular vote
got to decide thanks to
the votes from republican senators from
disproportionately lower population
states giving these republican senators
outsized influence i'm going from memory
here and don't hold me to this but we
looked at a statistic where something
like
oh my i think it was
senator in you could have a situation
where you have a majority in the senate
with the senators that represent only 17
of the american population
because of that population skew i hope
that makes sense
so it makes sense to me that you are
seeing this swing as
many have noted you don't usually see
such significant swings on major issues
of public opinion something that it's
not every day people don't think every
day about do i do i have confidence in
the supreme court or don't i that's not
something most people think about every
day people are busy living their lives
and working and to see such a drastic
swing
um in such a short period of time isn't
common and so on the one hand
it's good in that lots of people seem to
be paying attention to something that
they often wouldn't
on the other hand
we don't really have much recourse here
and that's by design and that would be
fine assuming we felt good about the
process i don't and i'm curious to hear
from you
one of the
funniest little details in this entire
saga of people protesting at the homes
of not only supreme court justices but
also republican senators is that
republican senator susan collins from
maine
decided to call the police because there
was chalk writing on the sidewalk
outside of her house this is like the
epitome of the triggered snowflake and i
i
i am sensitive to
others being sensitive about protests at
their homes and we had a very good
conversation on the show yesterday with
coleman hughes about it
but the police over chalk
when you supposedly are a defender of
speech you know the the free the i'm
fine having a good faith conversation
about protests at people's houses i'm
glad to do it
but when you're talking about
free speech absolutists who all of a
sudden say chalk isn't okay
that's a bit of a problem business
insider reports susan collins called the
police to report quote defacement of
public property after someone wrote an
abortion rights message in chalk on a
public sidewalk outside of her house
republican senator susan collins of
maine one of just two nominally
pro-choice republicans in the senate
called the police saturday night because
of an abortion rights message written in
chalk in front of her house in bangor
maine
according to the banger daily news
officers responded to a call at 9 20
because a message appeared on the
sidewalk it read susie please mainers
want whpa vote yes clean up your mess
whpa means the women's health protection
bill which would codify abortion rights
afforded by roe v wade into federal law
this is an idea that is an important
idea it's being increasingly discussed
well okay the supreme court can overturn
roe v wade by legal precedent but if we
codify
abortion rights into federal law
it overrides and supersedes that
the message was not overtly threatening
said wade betters a spokesperson for the
police department we are grateful
that susan collins said to the daily
news we are grateful to the banger
police officers and the city public
works employees who responded to the
defacement of public property in front
of our home
guys i mean we're not talking about
poster paint here we're not talking
about spray paint we're talking about
chalk which washes away when it rains or
with a bucket or a hose to call this
defacement this isn't graffiti this is
what kids do all the time they write
with chalk on the sidewalk and um
there's this
i don't want to put all of this on susan
collins because it's not it's not
uniquely her that's the hypocrite here
but it's the big picture of all of this
on the one hand republicans have been so
hesitant to say
the president led and incited an
insurrection and there should be no
consequences on the one hand
and then on the other hand someone wrote
with chalk call the cops
it it's it's one of these uh the the
message here
is a message of authoritarianism
of shutting down public speech and
protest throwing things in a senator at
a senator of course not absolutely not
going on the property of individuals to
prote absolutely not
um you know what whatever else
no
writing with chalk on the sidewalk that
seems like a real problem uh uh when
that now becomes something that police
are called over you can't write with
chalk on a sidewalk
but then you can tell the woman to carry
a pregnancy to term or you don't want to
hold trump accountable for the things
that he did so i think that this is an
outrageous
little micro episode about how the big
picture conversation is kind of missing
the forest for the trees and and by the
way i got a few angry emails after my
conversation yesterday with coleman
hughes from people saying david how can
you be
worried about protests at someone's
house
when women are being disenfranchised
from even being able to make decisions
about their own bodies decisions which
can be life and death they're two
separate situations
i am
you completely overwhelmingly
unequivocally disgusted by what we
believe to be the forthcoming decision
on roe v wade
and i also think there's a good faith
discussion to be had
about protesting at the houses of
supreme court justices these it's okay
to be able to discuss the two things
separately and a handful of people or so
maybe more like a dozen
didn't like that we were even having the
discussion and by the way i also have a
problem with that i know about this
whole we're just asking questions thing
and how it can be used to cover
uh in ways that aren't particularly
productive oh when when tucker says
some people say
10 000 people died from the covet
vaccine we're just asking questions on
the show i i get the the problem
problematic nature of just asking
questions but to say i shouldn't even be
having the conversation about protest
strategy and tactics
no guys that that's not uh
that that that's not any kind of support
of robust discussion that i can agree
with so maybe rethink that we will have
more on all of these stories on the
david pakman show instagram which you
can find at david pakman show and if you
want to see me
with a big black and white animal was it
a cow or was it a zebra many people are
asking what exactly was the animal i was
pictured with
follow me on my personal instagram at
david.pacman we'll take a quick break
and be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show okay so there's like a
wacky almost funny element to this story
and then there's a very real scary
politically substantive
element to this story
we're going to start with a video from
it's so hard to even say what this is i
believe that this is a christian church
okay
and
this is a rant at a christian church
about how the right the religious right
wants to take control of the educational
system
and use the educational system to
indoctrinate students with a
conservative right-wing reactionary
christian bible-based worldview as they
see it this is really scary
now what's the wacky part about it well
i can't tell whether this is a christian
church or an insane asylum there's
people screaming you'll notice that
while the guy on the microphone is
ranting
you'll hear other voices and if you're
watching you'll see people in the
background
talking over the guy
at one point it seems like the guy is
speaking in tongues i think although i'm
not an expert in speaking in tongues
and this is a movement where i can't
tell whether this is a church or an
insane asylum take a look at this now
lord according to your word we take
authority over our education system and
lord we call for righteousness in our
education system truth in our education
system justice in our education i think
the woman over the guy's right shoulder
just keeps saying
that's right that's right that's right
that's right i don't it seems almost
like this is a uh
it seems like the spirit has overtaken
them
we cast down that demonic hold of
indoctrination in our education system
so anyway now the guy's casting a spell
i guess to take control of schools and
god we declare that there's no education
outside of the word of the living god
there's no true education outside of the
the other oh well hold on i almost
talked over the tongues hold on a second
education outside of the
river
right
[Laughter]
so
extremely dangerous view about education
we want to take over education with
christianity
but also they're speaking in tongues and
screaming and it seems like everybody
should be medicated word of the living
god we declare according to your word
that all of our children shall be
disciples taught of the lord and great
shall be the peace and undisturbed
composure of our children so god we call
for righteousness in every level of
education i call forth righteousness
does anybody know why everybody's
talking over this guy in the background
i mean it's a bizarre scene
superintendents righteous teachers
righteous principles righteous
righteousness now and that by
righteousness and the word of
righteousness the demonic and the
deception and the evil that is taught in
the classroom would be driven up by the
hand of god driven out by the hand of
god
driven out now by the hand of god and
god i thank you for young people who are
taught according to your word in jesus
name so
i i don't even really understand what
the hell is going on there but
the really serious part is
they want to take over public education
and now for a slightly
just as just as wrong but less obviously
out of their mind view on this
we go to a clip of tony perkins tony
perkins the well-known homophobic
right-wing christian activist that we've
followed for for a long time on the show
he said well listen we want young
conservatives
to go into teaching
in public schools so that we can put our
christian world view into public schools
despite the fact that you're not that's
that's against the law they're supposed
to be separation of church and state
you're not supposed to be teaching
christianity
um
other than as a comparative religious
type class in public schools this is
their plan listen to tony perkins i
don't think we should abandon the public
schools i i encourage young people who
want to go into the teaching profession
to see the public schools as a mission
field we cannot abandon it we need to
run for the school board we need to be
teachers we need to be administrators
but we don't need to sacrifice our
children understand what he means by the
public schools or a mission field
he's talking about missionaries in the
same way that missionaries would go to
you know over the years they would go to
brazil
and make first contact in the amazon and
and try to bring convert people to
christianity he's saying see the public
schools as a mission field where we go
in and do the exact same thing
in that environment so i am not saying
we abandon the public schools we too
many kids are going to continue to go
there
but it shouldn't be our kids we should
send our our kids as teachers and
instructors right so that what tony
perkins is saying is and think about
this is dark ages stuff
this is
let's do the following here's the idea
our kids we send to christian private
schools where they get or we do
christian homeschooling which is
remember the overwhelming majority of
homeschooling in the u.s is is christian
oriented i think 75 close to 80 of it
their kids they do christian
homeschooling or christian private
schools but then they still infect the
public schools with their ideology
by taking the kids who went to the
christian private schools
having them go into teaching and then
send them into the public schools also
to teach christianity and to see it as a
mission field as they say to be
missionaries
in public schools which at least in
theory
are supposed to abide by separation of
church and state this is really scary
stuff so like listen i i get it
the guy speaking in tongues it's crazy
where we say medicate everyone
psych eval 72 hour hold but
they have money at least some
they're well organized relatively
speaking
and this is exactly
what they they're telling us what
they're planning to do and we know it's
what they're planning to do and when you
look at the level of organization i mean
look when the when the school mask and
vaccine stuff got going during coven
as the vaccines came out
um that level of organization it was a
lot of these same people who were
showing up to the school board meetings
they are organized there's no doubt
about it and so if we don't take this
threat seriously uh they may be far more
successful than maybe we're willing to
admit
speaking of conspiracy theories i want
to talk now about fox host maria
bartiromo
back in january a republican gave maria
the idea that there's going to be a
mid-term covet variant the idea being
that this is a contrived imaginary
variant meant specifically
for democrats i guess
to
justify
new or returning mandates related to the
pandemic and i guess somehow help them
win in november although i'll be honest
i don't even know how a midterm variant
would help democrats in the sense that
if all of a sudden you need lots of new
restrictions
and it's democrats that are in power
wouldn't voters say oh look democrats
have failed us because we've got to do
restrictions again it doesn't even make
any sense to me but maria bartoromo
likes it so here's where she first got
the idea this was during an interview in
january with
u.s senate candidate the current
missouri attorney general eric schmidt
he seemed to have kind of given her the
idea of a midterm variant and she liked
it take a look back with the ag of
missouri eric schmidt and uh a.g you
also questioned the timing of the
mandates and why he circumvented
congress and put it all on osha which
doesn't have such legislative authority
no and i think that's exactly right you
think back here
joe biden had taken this off the table
he had said many times that he wasn't
going to have a vaccine mandate
afghanistan happened which is perhaps
the worst foreign policy disaster in
generations a betrayal of the american
soldier billions of dollars of equipment
left behind
a total disaster and then immediately
after that to change the narrative he
announces these vaccine mandates which
are clearly unconstitutional unlawful
and you know why the supreme court
agreed with us in court last week but i
think it was a distraction and a cynical
one at that and the american people
deserve better but look this has never
been about the policy this is about
power and control and they're going to
continue to do this you watch maria
the things that he can't get done
legislatively is going to continue to
move forward administratively whether
it's on quote-unquote climate change
we've got an existential threat we've
got uh you know all we're at a tipping
point he's going to charge the deputy
under secretary of the epa who's not
accountable to anybody to do these
things and we're going to push back if
he can't get federal you know he can't
federalize the elections there'll be a
midterm variant watch that's coming
where he empowers administrative
agencies but the good news here is the
states are going to continue to fight
back to protect individual rights and
help save this country
yeah i think you're right about that
midterm election variant it's it's a
great point
so there was maria bartoromo first
getting that idea
and now she's repeating this constantly
i'm not going to play all five or six
examples of it for you but here is one
from
her show two days ago this was from her
um fox business mornings with maria
program
here she is now she's taken this midterm
variant thing hook line and sinker we
don't know the extent of the
investigation yet maria and i think the
reason for doing this the reason this
guy has stepped in and put up millions
of dollars to take care of hunter biden
bailing him out once again
is that it's pretty embarrassing for the
president of the united states to have
his son go to jail i mean the bottom
line they do probably have a cause uh
for indicting hunter biden and putting
him on trial and nobody
on the left wants to see that happen but
i have to say this whole thing i i mean
i think when republicans take over
control of congress which i hope and
expect to happen in november i think
there's going to be a lot of
investigation of really what has gone on
here where does all this money come from
if hunter biden's been making so much
money on ukrainian and chinese and
russian deals how in the world did he
not pay his taxes why did that happen
why was he lying to the irs because
that's basically what you're talking
about uh i think it's astonishing that
all this has gone on and the liberal
media continues to be completely
uninterested in the story
yeah well you said when the republicans
take over how about if the republicans
take over because the washington post is
reporting more covid
on the horizon in the fall as i've been
predicting the midterms variant
okay the midterms vary all right so
let's break this down in in pieces
first and foremost have democrats
created any variant of course not no
that's absurd are there more and more
coveted cases yes in fact covet cases
are spiking dramatically i'm not
necessarily saying anything in
particular should be done i'm not giving
you my medical opinion because i'm not a
doctor what i'm telling you is covet
cases are increasing dramatically the
u.s was down up to about 28 000 official
cases a day in late march
the u.s is now all the way back up to 70
000 cases a day and with so many people
not testing at all
or testing at home and not reporting
that they're sick
the real number of infections could be 2
or even three times as high we might
already be back up to somewhere between
150 000 and 200 000 cases a day am i
saying that we should do anything
differently no i'm not saying anything
one way or the other that's for medical
experts to decide but cases are spiking
like crazy that's number one number two
maria bartoromo seems to be suggesting
that it is the democrats that come up
with strategically timed contrived uh
stories or issues
meant to benefit them in elections but
the truth is that it's republicans who
have a very long history of doing that
ebola in 2014 i remember reporting on it
eight years ago
leading up to the midterm elections of
2014 rep i remember covering rand paul i
remember i remember i see myself sitting
in the old studio covering these stories
republicans were going crazy about the
ebola pandemic which was essentially
uh contained in west africa i think that
there were between two and four
cases that got to the u.s
one of which died and they they didn't
even catch it in the us i don't remember
the details but we're talking about
numbers you can count on one hand
and i told everybody
this issue disappears the day after the
midterms
and we never heard about it again after
the midterms that was a contrived issue
by republicans another example the
migrant caravans every time we start
getting close to an election fox news
migrant caravan is departing in
nicaragua heading all the way up they're
expected at the u.s mexico border six
weeks eight weeks from now what
democrats aren't doing anything about it
the migrant caravan story is a contrived
issue
with the timing meant to help
republicans in
elections midterm elections and general
elections voter fraud i mean again
that was timed starting six months
before the 2020 election to have a very
particular effect which i won't even go
into now because you all know about it
already
it is the republicans who do the
carefully and deliberately timed fake
issues
a midterm variant what we have is
another coveted spike
and why we have it and what should be
done are not the topics for this segment
but the idea that democrats have uh uh
created that in any way is completely
absurd and the really sad thing is i've
said it before
maria bartoromo used to be a good
financial reporter 20 years ago when i
first got into following the stock
market i'd watch her on cnbc in the
morning before school she really was
doing good financial reporting she's
become a conspiracy nut trump brown
noser and it's a really a shame it
really is
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
one of the biggest questions if elon
musk does successfully purchase twitter
is whether he's going to let donald
trump back on twitter donald trump was
banned from twitter permanently in 2021
uh remember there are some who say that
trump was banned from twitter in order
to hurt him in the 2020 election he
wasn't banned until 2021 so assuming
time moves forward which i think we sort
of think it does unless you want to get
into some metaphysical stuff um that
isn't true but trump was banned from
twitter in 2021. elon musk was recently
asked would you let him back on twitter
and elon musk said that he would now i
have some thoughts about this that some
in my audience may not agree with i'll
get to those in a moment let's first
listen to what elon musk said
are you planning to let donald trump
back on
well
i think there's
there's a general question of
should was twitter have permanent bans
um
and you know i've talked with jack
dorsey about this and
he and i are of the same mind which is
that uh permanent bands should be uh
extremely rare and really reserved for
uh
people where they're trying to uh before
for accounts that are
bots or
spam scam accounts
where there's just no legitimacy to the
account at all
um i do think that uh
it was not correct
to
ban donald trump i think that was that
was a mistake
um
because it uh
it alienated a large part of the country
and did not ultimately result in donald
trump not having a voice he is not going
to be on truth social um as will a large
part of the
sort of the the
right in the in the united states
um and so
i think this could end up being frankly
worse than having a sing you know a
single forum where everyone can debate
um so
um
i guess the answer is that i i i would
reverse the permaban i'll say i'm not i
don't own twitter yet so this is not
like a thing that will definitely happen
because what if i don't own twitter
but my opinion and jack dorsey i want to
be clear shares this opinion uh is that
we should not have perma permabans um
now now that doesn't okay
so elon musk says
he thinks trump was wrongly banned now
uh donald trump was rightly banned let's
go through this in stages okay
um trump broke twitter terms of service
absolutely
trump should have been banned
however i am very much in the direction
of
lifetime bans should be extremely rare
and trump probably shouldn't have gotten
a lifetime ban i'm not saying he should
be unbanned today i would be completely
fine with it having been okay
you incite violence that's a five-year
ban or ten or three or it doesn't even
really matter the specifics of it but i
generally don't believe in irreversible
decisions not that a twitter ban is like
the death penalty but i am against the
death penalty because if you make a
mistake you can't undo it once you've
executed somebody so permanent bans for
bot accounts um
accounts that are fake pretending to be
someone else impersonation um automated
activity absolutely no no question about
that those are bands for life that
that's just a purging trash right i mean
we do we we perma ban all of that stuff
on uh you know on all of our platforms
when we see it when we see that type of
thing
when it comes to
violations of terms of service i still
am okay with some bans for life but
they've got to be like i don't even know
you know you live stream yourself
committing a crime
murdering someone what a lifetime ban
youtube does that all these that that
that's okay
but even as bad as what trump did was
and he did really bad things i mean you
can argue that his actions
you can argue his actions in total and
twitter was part of it led to real world
violence and it's terrible and he should
have been banned i still lean towards
most cases are a ban for a specific
amount of time
subject to review and revision and i
would be fine for that review and
revision to determine trump gets another
three years
or whatever i'm totally totally fine
with that
but i would lean heavily in the
direction of uh these are for a sort of
specified amount of time in general now
when when we talk about trump
specifically realistically
he may never change
uh
and he might get back on and do the
exact same stuff
um in which case you might say well
there's no reason to think he'd do
anything differently and so we're going
to keep him banned i'm fine with that
the other problem there's there's two
other problems with this anyway and it's
sort of like a fraught question
one is we know that terms of service are
inconsistently applied they're
inconsistently applied in different
cases based on how prominent accounts
are and they're inconsistently applied
also uh just on the basis of content we
that's just a thing and i'm not saying
that they're inconsistently applied in
terms of a left or right wing bias that
is a debate but i'm not even dipping
into that right now just terms of
service are inconsistently applied and
we experience that as well
there are on youtube for example
there are
because our content is seen by more
people than channels with a thousand
subscribers
there are lots of things we get
demonetized for that other really small
channels don't get hit with just because
no one's paying attention and you can
argue that that's right or wrong or
whatever but we have an inconsistent
application of terms of service and then
the other thing is
i am right there with you
that the idea of the bans get reviewed
who does the reviewing and do we trust
them to do the reviewing and i don't
have an answer to that right now so i'm
speaking in principle
i think for the most part we should
almost never have bands for life extend
them whatever almost like a parole
hearing i'm fine with that do you trust
the people you put in charge to do it
becomes a real question i want we have
not talked about jordan peterson for a
while
but he is back on the sort of speaking
trail and um our colleague john sent me
this clip uh from jordan peterson at
stanford university a few days ago this
was on i guess it was a couple weeks ago
this was a
sort of an event on classical liberalism
at the graduate school of business at
stanford university
and um
i don't even know how to explain this
jordan peterson started weeping
because he's so upset about climate
activism not climate change he's not
upset because of climate change he's
upset because of climate activism and he
seems unstable completely unhinged
really seems to have lost it i'm going
to play a couple minutes because you've
got to see the lead up and the lead-up
is he finds it so upsetting that
sometimes people are negative about the
outlook of the planet and humanity and
he says that the problem is that
people are being
uh
people are getting depressed because of
climate activists okay check this out
shouldn't even have any children
it's like
no
there's no excuse for that there's zero
excuse for that i saw a professor at an
event something like this
he came out and trumpeted this bloody
environmentally friendly house he built
and you know fair enough man it was it
was a pretty interesting house but
not everybody had the four million
dollars that that it took him to build
it and i'm not criticizing his money
even it's like
he's had some money good for him he
built a house okay but then to trumpet
that as a moral virtue well you're
pushing it there and then he came out to
all the kids and he said you know my
wife and i decided that we're only going
to have one child and i think that's one
of the most ethical things we could have
possibly done and i would strongly
encourage you to do the same i thought
you son of a [ __ ] you get up in front
of these young people a lot of these
kids were
uh children of first generation
immigrants from china and and he showed
all these images you know of these
terrible factories in china these
endless rows of sterile mechanism that
were subordinating all the chinese
people to this terrible you know
capitalist uh machine and i thought if
you're still following this
it's about to get really weird i don't
understand half the audience is looking
at those factories and thinking that's a
hell of a lot better than struggling
through the mud under mao buddy
and so he
i don't know where he thought he was but
to come out in front of all those kids
and basically tell them that the whole
human enterprise is so goddamn corrupt
that the best thing they could possibly
do is limit their multiplication and to
think of himself as a scholar and an
educator it was just i did say something
by the way it was rather uncomfortable
and he stomped off the stage but
that's no message for young people
that's no there's no excuse for that you
think well you know we're going to
destroy the planet we have to do this we
have to demoralize the youth to be
ethical it's like yeah really that's
your theory you're going to demoralize
young people to be ethical that's your
theory it's like you should go and think
about that for like a year and i'm
passionate about this you know because
you have no idea how many people that's
killing
you have no idea i see people everywhere
all over the world they're so
demoralized
especially
young people especially
young people with a conscience because
they've been told since they were little
that there's nothing to them but
corruption and power it's like how the
hell do you expect them to react
so he
this is bizarre obviously there's a real
difference between young people are told
that you are made up of corruption and
and whatever
and hey we have some hard problems that
we're facing and they need to be solved
and you might make choice i mean there's
an entire movement i think it's called
the anti-natalist which basically says
like we can't bring people we we should
all everybody should stop reproducing
because
we are
rapidly heading towards lack of
sustainability and on and on and on now
i happen to disagree with that i think
the way we solve our problems is
actually
by reproducing and creating people that
are going to solve these problems that's
that's my view because i i guess i'm
more optimistic than pessimistic but
this whole thing weeping because people
learn
that
things aren't looking so good in some
senses that it would be immoral to hide
everyone from that now i'm with you you
we don't want to demoralize people no we
want to say hey the we've look at all
these problems humanity has solved
and then here are the problems now
facing us and let's solve them but i
would be crying over how we're
destroying the planet
not about how kids might find it
upsetting that we're destroying the
planet that seems very very backwards
and another one of these really weird
weepy he it just he seems emotionally
disregulated is what that seems like and
also
sort of wrong on the facts if you can be
both at once which clearly you can
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
we had a discussion the other day about
what i call the smoked salmon bagel
index it's like my version of the big
mac or the whopper index where i go okay
like what's a smoked salmon bagel cost
in different places and the egg man
wrote in with what is quite frankly not
a good suggestion take a listen to this
or he called in rather
hey dave i have a question about the
smoked salmon bagel index please in
western new york where i live you can
buy the um smoked salmon cream cheese
spread it's like
cream cheese and lox spread mixed
against that pink cream cheese right and
then you put that on a bagel it's like
having smoked salmon
and cream cheese on your bagel right
yeah you know i mean listen i think
everybody should have whatever they want
i reject the notion and i reject it
wholeheartedly that is a freaking
predator right there yes that uh the the
the pink cream cheese that has some
smoked salmon kind of uh
blended into it
is the same as properly putting smoked
salmon on the bagel it's it's just i
can't and i know we're getting very deep
into jewish cuisine here
it's a really tough uh i'm not gonna die
on this hill but it's a tough thing for
me to accept
you get one of those for like a couple
of bucks
is that good enough for you or do you
actually need the actual smoked salmon
and the capers all that stuff for
17 bucks 11 bucks
shalom brother yeah i mean listen i'm
not a buyer at 17 bucks for a smoked
salmon bagel
but uh at prices south of that you'll
certainly find me find me considering it
but no listen uh honestly that that
smoked salmon cream cheese
it's not bad it's not bad it's just a
whole different thing it's a completely
different element and i think everybody
should be aware of that we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today by
the way how many people will be mad
because they are taking the smoked
salmon
segment seriously
unfortunately probably dozens that's a
sad it's a sad thing on today's bonus
show
insurrectionist senator josh hawley
is introducing a measure to strip disney
of copyright protections
these people with their hypocrisy they
love copyright protections they want
patent protection forever for
pharmaceuticals and all this stuff oh
disney doesn't like the don't say gay
bill strip them of copyright protection
josh hawley horrible person we'll talk
about that there is a bill
that will help women pay to travel to
california
for abortions if needed
the bill is moving forward we are going
to talk about that and also after this
viral video of boxer mike tyson
showed him
punching an airline passenger
uh he is not going to be charged for
that and we will talk about why and what
the different elements of that legal
decision are
all on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpackman.com i can't wait to see you
on today's bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad if alex jones doesn't like it
you can be damn sure that you probably
will you can use the coupon code obama
to get a discount off of your choice of
membership at joinpakman.com you must
spell it correctly it's like correctly
incorrectly
o b a m
n a
and you'll get a great discount we'll
see you on the bonus